Je croyais des trucs tellement débiles,
quand j'étais gamin !
J'aimerais,
j'aimerais tellement remonter le temps,
me rencontrer petit et
m'expliquer à quel point j'étais con.
Cyprien,
je suis toi dans le futur.
Waouh,
j'suis devenu chirurgien !
Non.
Pompier volontaire ?
Tu vas devenir YouTubeur.
Euh.. tu vas faire
des vidéos sur Internet.
Des vidéos qui vont s'afficher
sur plein d'ordinateurs.
Mais c'est génial !
Dans le futur, y'a des voitures qui volent ?
Aaaah, non.
On peut se téléporter ?
Non. Faut qu'j'te dise, le logo Carrefour,
c'est pas un visage penché.
Ben si. On peut clairement voir
les deux yeux, la bouche...
Non.
C'est un C dans un losange.
Ah oui, et celui de la Caisse d'Epargne,
c'est pas un logo abstrait, c'est un écureuil.
Allez, salut !
Ah oui,
Michael Jackson est mort.
Quand j'étais petit,
je croyais que l'eau de toilette,
c'était de l'eau.. des toilettes.
Excusez-moi,
mais vous puez la merde !
Merci.
Bonne journée.
Quand j'étais petit,
je croyais que dans les drogueries,
on vendait de la drogue.
Du coup dans ma tête,
je pensais que la drogue c'était illégal,
et en même temps,
un peu légal.
Police ! Vous vendez de
la drogue ici ? Hein ?
Oui
Très bien, continuez comme ça.
Bonne journée.
Vous voulez du crack ?
D'la MD ?
Quand j'étais petit,
je croyais que le cochon d'Inde,
c'était un cochon-dinde.
Et en fait, non.
Ca n'a rien à voir, hein.
En même temps, je sais pas qui a décidé
que cet animal allait être un cochon.
Hein, euh..
un gros hamster, à la limite...
Quand j'étais petit,
je croyais que pendant l'accouchement,
perdre les eaux,
c'était perdre les os.
Ce qui n'était pas.. normal.
Bon écoutez, l'accouchement
s'est bien passé, l'enfant va bien,
par contre
on a perdu vos deux tibias. Voilà.
Ah, c'est pour ça que
je tiens plus debout.
J'viens d'en retrouver un,
il était juste tombé ! Hein ?
Quand j'étais petit, je croyais que
quand mes parents roulaient la nuit,
la lune nous suivait.
Maman !
Maman, prends à droite.
Maman, prends à droite
maintenant, maintenant !
On est suivis, maman.
Quand j'étais petit et que
je jouais à cache-cache,
attention, je croyais qu'il suffisait que
je me cache les yeux pour qu'on ne me voie plus.
En fait,
on me voit encore.
Enfin, je crois.
Quand j'étais petit, je croyais que
mes jouets étaient vivants la nuit.
Oui, comme dans Toy Story euh...
Oui, j'étais très influençable,
c'est vrai.
Je sais que t'es vivant, mais ne t'inquiète pas,
je ne le dirai à personne.
Ca restera notre secret.
OK, ça marche.
Aaaaaaah !!!!
Quand j'étais petit,
je trouvais que ceux qui n'avaient pas
la télévision étaient carrément bizarres.
Maintenant, c'est ceux qui la regardent
que je trouve chelous.
Quand j'étais petit, je faisais vachement gaffe
au petit logo en bas à droite
pendant les films à la télévision.
Par exemple,
quand j'avais neuf ans et demi
et que je regardais un film
déconseillé aux moins de dix ans,
j'me sentais comme un...
hors la loi.
Bon, en vrai,
je regrette un petit peu.
Puis aujourd'hui,
j'ai l'impression que c'est,
que c'est plus trop... d'actualité, hein.
Pour mes huit ans,
j'ai demandé Call of Duty !
Quand j'étais petit, j'avais peur de
faire dépasser mes pieds du lit.
Parce que je croyais qu'il y avait
un monstre caché sous mon lit
qui allait me les attraper,
comme ça.
Comme si les monstres se disaient :
Ah, mince,
ses pieds dépassent plus !
Comment j'peux faire, moi,
maintenant ?
Il m'a bien baisé !
J'pourrais sortir,
j'pourrais l'attraper, mais non !
Il a rangé ses pieds. Merde !
Et toi ? Tu croyais quoi,
quand t'étais petit ?
Hein ?
Lâche un comm'.
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle